um so I have some handouts
um one of the handouts is just a very
small videography of some of the
relevant literature and trying to
summarize some of the
arguments or findings from that another
one is you're probably all familiar with
the Goldberg scale of moral development
in fact Holmberg itself wrote some
things on in prisons
he did some of his research I think
physics
so the other the other things are some
exercises that will do along the way
and there's variety of answers
you may have started out actually I
needed a job that was the available job
so I took it on
the
the first thing that I heard from
somebody who've done a lot of
orientation sessions at Indiana stateism
was that there's two good things in
prison education and religion everything
else is bad so you're bringing something
to these men that they can appreciate it
and that was that was true
um
another
important motive is involving oneself in
positive transformation of the inmates
and you can think of this in Social
terms in terms of recidivism
how many how many of these people are
returning to the president and there are
a lot of studies that show that
educational achievements in prison
correlated with lowering recipients
whether it's even just getting a GED
once you start getting to college
education recidivism goes down
dramatically and it's not it's not
simply due I think to Greater
employability
I think that a lot of it has to do with
with
passes for moral transformation
Rehabilitation is part of that I can say
that I've actually seen Rehabilitation
taking place in individuals and in
groups of individuals associated with
each other voluntarily within the prison
I was privileged in that because of the
program that I was in I could I could
observe inmates class after class after
class throughout their entire college
career
so that was very helpful for that
uh
it could be part of your personal or
professional growth
working in a prison
gives you another environment to try
things out in to see whether you know
glossary really is applicable or not
it's very different from the Beyond
campus setting that we're used to and uh
for many people it can be a form of
service to the community or to those who
are incarcerated or you know the wider
network of people that are effective but
my incarceration
so that those are all motives for doing
for doing it what about opportunities it
varies from state to state
prison education
has been on the attack for about the
last 15 years a lot of states have
canceled their their programs that have
been dealt with explicitly they're only
about 11 states that still have
full-born prison education programs that
are funded by the state in the end is
one of them North Carolina is one I
don't know if South Carolina has
some of them are degree programs some of
them are just course programs
where they they take a smattering of
courses but then they can they can use
that when they get out to transfer into
a college
there's also initiatives by institutions
and I wanted to point out The Bard
prison initiative which is connected
with these these other state types as
well but where an institution actually
decided it wanted to take an active role
more active role than some of the
universities that participated in prison
education there's also the possibility
of affiliating with volunteer programs
or groups
if your state doesn't have prison
education they may very well have
character based or faith-based
prison
form
sort of self-modification programs and
they're always looking for volunteers to
teach in those ethics is quite often
then there's independent initiatives and
some people are
fairly entrepreneurial at this they just
contact a prison I have a friend up at
St anselms College who brings employment
and discusses platonic dialogues with
prisoners of the women's prison
and he doesn't have any backing from
Saint Ansel himself or from the doc it's
just something that goes on but there's
a lot of room for those
a little part because
what I found at least with the Indiana
Doc in the North Carolina Doc is that
the guards the
Administration they recognize the value
of Education
sometimes it's purely instrumental if
they're in the classroom they're not
they're not out in their cell blocks
making trouble
but also gives them something if they're
in a full-blown program it gives them
something that can be taken away from
them so it's good for
something that way but there are many
correctional officers and administrators
who really support prison education
it's a question often to find your
resources
one of the things that I'd like to do
with the first handout that I've given
you is to just take a moment and do a
little bit of reflection
and think about what are your two most
important goals in teaching ethics
courses nice from all of you get to
teach ethics courses from time to time
and so put it put aside any of the
accreditation business that we all have
to go through every five to ten years
and just think about what is it that you
really want students to get from your
ethics courses
and then after that
um if you were to teach in prison
what would you want what content would
you want them to take away from your
Ethics Course
so what are some of your your answers to
the first one
the Mythic students it would be a
facilitate empathy in them and also to
an appreciation of the complexity of
ethical decision making
uh moral reasoning skills
to be one and also respect for diversity
and perspective which would be something
in empathy yeah
will they be mutually supportive
I want them to be more ethical but
specifically through
understanding their own uh competences
psychological competences emotional
rational
um volitional that go into
um at the ethical confidence yeah
reflections
but some of you put for
the second part
let's say you were to teach them
content
what is it that from the course
yeah
did you have a change based on
who the students were
okay
yeah I wrote the same things except
more for the 18 year olds in my college
than 22 year olds I want them to think
they can do it you know when they read
mail or con or Plato they're always like
oh my gosh it's the dead white man you
know come I can't possibly you know and
like well no let's look at some of those
examples or some you know you're not
you're not going to get your music in
Plato's Republic because that'll corrupt
you oh well that's not right and so they
can actually get in there and do it and
I don't know if that kind of confidence
mattered as much or maybe more for your
students the person but
my students were older yeah
the average age is around 25 and so that
really helped
yeah the question of whether this
stuff that they're studying is actually
applicable
that that sparked a lot of conversations
I
like my students to be aware that the
positions they and others hold
almost always have some assumption very
behind it yeah
predisposed to looking for that and
examine what are the assumptions of the
positions
yeah
um
often when we Joseph has probably heard
this many times when we
teach in prisons and tell people oh you
gotta catalog
that's not exactly true really you're
the one who's
the captain
because we're going in if you're going
to teach in the prison you're teaching a
very different environment
Justin's already talked a little bit
about that
and it's very different moral
environment
there's there's the challenges that
opposed by the institution itself
there's a lot of them that inhibit or
interfere with education and so
what I've
come to think of overtime I didn't do
this at first
I had to sort of threw things together
is you really need to adopt a sort of
dialect
but things are affecting things from
both sides I mean there has to be a
reflection
what it is we're actually trying to
achieve in the classes and then course
design I become a great believer in
actually spending a lot of time on
designing courses before you actually
throw the students into them and then
some some engaging practices within the
courses themselves that can tie in with
the communities that exist within any
um
some of the conditions and challenges
for teaching ethics you have the
correctional institution itself
and structuring a time and the lack of
very good educational resources and
spaces is one of the things that comes
out of that
the lives of the prison students
themselves that they're living within
the prison affects the educational
preparation of the students most
students in prison
that are going to college got their GED
in prison
States moral development of the students
I'm going to talk about that in a moment
on the kohlberg scale
inmates criminals in general tend to be
about level one and only two
and there are certain factors between
the prison itself tend to reinforce that
there's the instructors themselves there
we can constitute impediments to
education
so the setting itself one thing that
goes to the question about academic
freedom for example
being critical the education that
happens in a prison has to be compatible
with the good order of the institution
that's just a given you can't be telling
them
barricade yourself in and start burning
things
that that simply you know that's outside
of the realm of possibility that would
be to the harm of the prisoners anyway
and so
instance can be more or less receptive
to Educators coming in from the outside
prison staff of their own attitude some
of them are very resentful to the fact
that the prisoners are getting one to
them it seems like a free education and
others are very supportive of it
time is a big problem this is one that
you have less control over scheduling
tends to be seminar format because you
have to fit within the very regimented
blocks of time within the prison
there are unpredictable interruptions
you can have lockdowns where the entire
prison is locked down and everybody's in
their cells you can't teach them
but you you have to somehow get in the
content that you need to
sometimes you have to do emergency
accounts where they say okay everyone
has to leave the classroom we have to
count all the prisoners within the
institution most prisons count at least
two to three times a day
they know where they are educational
spaces and resources
and at Indiana State Prison they did
have computer labs a library classrooms
everything is very substandard
but you there's something to make do
the students themselves a lot of them
work
in maximum security prisons most jobs
within prisons are actually done by
prisoners because regarding them
sometimes food service has been
privatized but fire department tends to
be prisoners
the sanitation as prisoners all the
maintenance tends to be prisoners so
in my classes I would have some students
who were actually working 40 hours
the cell blocks or dorms can be very
noisy which makes it difficult to study
sometimes makes it difficult to
assignment stuff
educational preparation like I like I
said it tends to be these are all
underprepared students for the most part
there are exceptions but um
when you structure classes you should
hear it towards towards that level
moral development which we're a bit more
interested in here there are
correlations between lack of moral
development and crime there's no
one-to-one correlation it's not a thing
about necessary and sufficient
conditions because human beings are very
complex and there's also evolutional
factors involved but the culberg scale
is actually fairly useful for this
but it's very useful for thinking about
what we're going to do in prisons the
prison environment by itself does not
tend to promote moral development
uh it doesn't also necessarily
disinhibit it
it's not you know completely brutal
there there are prisons like that
tend to be in countries
so much of the community in our system
so
many of the students entering are at a
low level of development so this is this
is what I
myself ended up thinking about as I was
teaching
um
I found that I was actually not sure
and uh
these are things that you could ask
yourself if you were thinking about
teaching it
um what sort of obstacles would we bring
what sort of preconceptions about
prisoners about prisons about prison
staff any of those sort of things can
get in the way
well if uh
one of the problems that we tended to
have with
first year
professors was
um
it would be argumentative or have an
attitude with pristana
and if you're going into a prison
particularly particularly a Maximum
Security Prison you're in their
Institution
you make trouble
you're gonna have a very hard time
getting any sort of cooperation and you
need cooperation
um
one can also be sort of demeaning
towards the prisoners or standing office
towards them
and then you know some of these things
are unconscious they're they're going to
be a particularly
I always dress like this
like this yeah and I did that in my
previous
one of the prisoners told me about
another professor who wasn't there
anymore who
I usually taught in Fairly you know
fairly casual
and then one day he showed up in a suit
and tie and prisoners asked
um why are you so messed up are you
going to you know dinner or something
like that and the guy said no I'm going
to teach my real students on campus
so that sort of thing and you know very
quickly
turns people off it takes a bad
classroom environment wow but what you
know where did that come from
preconception
in the last one because I suspect a lot
of people in this room might be
motivated to teach because of those
kinds of businesses yeah and and what
the way I'm getting at this is when I
teach ethics I when I do feminist ethics
we do the Gilligan continued Culvert
yeah and then I talked about the
psychology faculty I know who say
everyone thinks kohlberg is a bad bad
psychology yeah but height and others
that do more reasoning they think
they've got something there that you can
test whereas the di1 and two dit one and
two the culprit that none of them think
that's valid and reliable they just
think it's awful so for example if we
were to do a unit on oral development in
the prison and I were to March out my
liberal Progressive critique of Goldberg
and you do Gilligans
because I mean just traditionally
speaking in terms of long theory about
conscience and very uh generic
principles at the very top yeah but of
course the Gilligan critique is the
girls never get and women don't get to
the top level on Culver because they're
deficient and I think that's pretty
liberal views
right but especially the girls the women
right they're doing group think and care
and you know we don't want to do that
they're at level three yeah right so you
know unless we want to think they're
morally backward yeah there's something
wrong but I mean could you have this
discussion oh yeah without them tagging
you with this logo Progressive yeah I
don't mean that's that's oh okay okay
I'm in the sort of pervasive I'm here to
fix the world
you know the prison system there's no
prison system in there
um
there are all sorts of docs and some of
them are very good some of them are bad
that conditions vary from prison to
prison to prison and
um so yeah when it comes down to it a
lot of the things that instructors come
into the classroom
and push as sort of the majority of you
students are distrustful of it
the discipline I only not only took
philosophy type religious studies the
religious studies has a real liberal
Health yeah
and so you know they could they could
see the textbooks
I'm pretty middle of the road I'm
critical
of that they they like that well I have
a colleague teaches in prisons and he
says the nice thing about it is that
they all see that there's a spin or a
game with everything right which is like
seeing the assumptions under the text so
he said he got bad but I'd be thinking
if I did offend this unit in ethics
would they be thinking man you're way
out there like those wacky academics
really it would depend on how you
pitched it okay
um this this idea of learning other
people's perspectives and being able to
say what it is that you you disagree
with and that that's that's part of
moral development that's part of what we
try to teach them in ethics classes and
but if you're if you're peddling in
something like feminism is good in and
of itself it's just a dominant
assumption I mean any here's the thing
with moral theory any moral theory if
we're really good philosophers has to
always be ready to provide a
justification throughout itself it can't
just assume that we're the good guys
we're going to come in and teach it and
that's that's what happens on both ends
of the ideological spectacular the right
and the letter do that just so happens
that most University professors tend to
be able to laugh
yeah Joseph made a point that I'd like
to go back to
he was self-preservation because um
when I teach I go into the audience with
a handheld might yeah can I do that in
prison oh yeah we had a professor who
had Parkinson's and so he was having
trouble um
and he had to um
he had to be given a microphone
um
a few years you know you're going to get
searched I mean I go into the students
with a hand-meld and I ask them
questions and I'll pass the mic around
remember like Phil Donahue yeah that's
not necessarily a problem that would
depend again on the doc that you're in
because some prison like Attica don't
think they don't negotiate with hostages
right
I mean it's a legitimate concern I think
I don't you know when I want to walk out
of there when I talk for Ball State in
Indiana
Allstate had been in Indiana prisons for
25 years
there was never an incident of an inmate
ever
physically threatening
and Ball State at the time that I left
so I had 135 professors full-time in
Indiana
um now one reason why this took place
why the you know nobody
messed with the professors was
if there was any incident that would
result in Ball State pulling out
and whoever did it would be immediately
targeted by all the other prisoners and
a lot of the prisoners form strong bonds
with great professors as well when the
riots took place at Newcastle
um there were Arizona prisoners who were
being housed in Indiana
I was in units They Ride
and we had Ball State professors behind
the riot lines the Indiana inmates
escorted the professors who were caught
behind the lines to the safe Zone
so
at least in that state like I wouldn't
want to teach for instance in the
California deals I consider that would
be just a complete hellhole it's
unmanageable nobody knows what's going
on there's no way I never teach that
because
seem to be pretty good about this sort
of thing would you teach like you're
doing a utilitarian unit would you teach
Phantoms at Opticon where you know
everyone well I always remarkable yeah
yeah okay
um but no when we teach utilitarianism
what I usually end up having them do and
they're very good at this and start
carrying out utilitarian calculations
and provide justifications for why
precisely this should be weighted this
way
I do want to talk about the the moral
development theory and then point out
somebody else another researcher who's
done a lot of work on this
um you're all familiar with what the
folders Theory
so there's this guy Stephen duguese and
he has been an administrator a professor
in the Canadian prison system
for a very long time he's done a lot of
thinking a lot of work on Prison
education and philosophy itself a lot of
this ties in closely with the rural
development so you see him in the
bibliography that
there's also some other useful
supplements for youth for thinking of
business holder of the ethics of care
actually a lot of phenomenological
approaches from the 20th century like
Gabriel Marcel and Dietrich schaler
do really the same thing about the
Gilligan
you get the same mileage out of them
that you go to the ethics to care
in a lot of ways the kohlberg approach
and the weeds approach are actually via
Aristotelian without realizing that they
because they presume that there's a
human potential that has to be developed
it doesn't develop automatically on its
own just by removing impediments that it
actually has to be fostered and steered
at certain points that the will is part
of that this this goes to some of the
questions that were being asked what
actually works what what's needed
um where do you put yourself as a
professor
like I put here education if it's going
to work it has to be something
additional
it recognizes that it's in an
institution
but it supplies something that that's
been lacking in that that is
it so it's not oppositional for the
prison system because that that's just a
recipe for perfect
but it doesn't allow itself to be
something co-opted and the prison
sometimes
docs will try to use the educational
plan that they have to get you to
monitor the prisoners
that's just the sort of part of the
course
another thing that it allows is in
incorporating and reflecting on students
experience and
you bring that um
somebody brought up the
need to actually reflect on one's
decision making the assumptions
everyone's doing bringing these things
into the light
a lot of times we've all experienced
this in ethics classes what happens to
students have ideas and they throw them
out on the table and they they want to
stay at that level they don't want to
provide justifications
for why they say this is the right thing
to do they just want to argue with each
other in the bad sense of shouting at
each other that that happens in prisons
a lot as well and we want to help
prisoners
learn how to step back and start
providing justifications
and doing that with their experiences as
well
um
another thing that's very important is
offering students involved in
identifications not only with the
community outside the prison
there's a lot of ways to do this but
also with there's this broad cultural
heritage that we call Humanities which I
think is very liberating it's
what Joseph was talking about
um I think weed makes a good argument
that what's really needed for moral
transformation are broad-based academies
he particularly he doesn't actually like
philosophy so much which is interesting
for a philosopher he says that the most
moral transformation probably takes
place in English and history classes and
I think that really has to do with the
way philosophers taught one one thing
that I myself
is
the typical analytic approach is not
going to be helpful from all
transformation what Joseph was calling
um a speculative philosophy or I would
call hermeneutical
philosophy or just sort of the broad
correct of the way we did philosophy
before the
movement that's what's needed something
that's fairly systematic that allows
them to have something to sink their
teeth into
gods
let's talk about this last thing if you
go to the uh the website that I have
listed on the top I'm going to be
uploading a lot of these materials there
so
as well as some other things I've done
prison education
so
you can you can get the full benefit of
the workshop here's one final problem
that we always have to worry about
and this is this ties in the course
design
um a lot of the learning has to take
place
outside of the classroom so the question
is how do we structure our classes this
is probably something you've all thought
quite a bit about already how do you
structure our classes so that our
students are engaged with the material
and coming to class and preparing having
actually digested it
and structured
build off of itself it has to integrate
things from their environment as well
this is what I I
um
I've been putting a lot of effort into
course design I also think that part of
it is planning ahead for the recurring
teachable moments that come up in our
classes I mean you're all
you all have those brilliant moments as
well as moments later on where some
student just lapses completely into
relativism and takes up 20 minutes of
class time
well that can be a great teachable
moment and it can be a great teachable
moment with talking about stages of
mobile development
why is this stance being you know put
out here as where we should be where the
classroom all of us in the holes should
be when we know there's something better
what is that something better and then
you let the students start to do that
and they will actually
come in and start criticizing each other
and saying yeah we covered that back in
the first week don't be a relativist
um and you can do that with uh sort of
tropes about egoism everybody is out for
themselves yeah have you ever thought
about filming your work and turning it
into a documentary
um
there's I mean there's obstacles to that
it could be done the Indiana POC
actually allowed something
is really remarkable they allowed some
some massive really high quality cameras
much about it
uh prison education
oh one of them too flexibility getting
ready to to change a course and I'll
give you a very quick example I taught a
contemporary philosophy class and we
focused on phenomenology for the most
part
and this doesn't tie in with the moral
reasoning or anything like that but for
sale some students did do some writing
uh using using Shayla
um and Marcel
I decided about halfway through the the
course that instead of just doing sort
of Doctrine Americans how
phenomenological analysis is carried out
even though we're going to read some
quick scroll then we're going to some
shield and all that to have them
actually do phenomenological analysis of
prison life
and try to get the game experience and
uh
that was a practice and I came up with
some really interesting material through
it so some of the material wasn't very
good
they didn't really know
not that interested in class with the
material that was very good and very
interesting
and I didn't I wasn't ready to
change the syllabus
halfway through the semester I didn't
have that sort of flexibility I couldn't
have done that I think actually teaching
in the prison system
since there's usually less oversight by
your
on-campus administrators
um there there are more materials in
here we're over time actually so
has this significantly improved your
teaching in the traditional classroom
yes I would imagine that it has yeah
um
precisely how
much
say right now but
um I've actually used examples from the
president in the classroom
for some reason
to not only pay attention but
other people
yes
and you know
where there has been education